les rangers un but injustement on ne
sait pas gaza
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on s'attend
à l'est déjà content déjà ça depuis quoi
c'est merveilleux c'est historique pour
notre cher pays et tout le continent
africain
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes très fiable de la victoire
derrière ce soir et j'ai apprécié
l'hommage tout le match a été bien beau
on a battu le burkina faso du maigre mal
aux deux équipes il en kayak et betty
difficutés que le co doit le voir
[Applaudissements]
les livres de comptes sont bien battus
et ils nous ont honorés de bout en bout
on a vu qu'ils ont raté beaucoup
d'occasions qui auraient pu et vendu le
score mais nous sommes contents ils nous
sommes très heureux de découvrir les
infrastructures et des livres pour la
can est de 1 on a fait un très beau
match et j'ai aussi apprécié le jeu du
bukina faso mais ils n'ont pas démérité
franchement on avait hâte on avait
rarement nous sommes siècle à cannes a
eu à a commencé je crois que ça se passe
bien pour le moment je crois que le
cameroun à l'automne et la lauter le
camry la russie et la russie cet
événement le cas mais ribéry
[Musique]
on est satisfait on savait que le
premier match n'est jamais un match
facile donc allez on sait qu'il ya des
millions des millions de camerounais qui
attendait ça vous voulez les trois
points c'est chose faite donc on est
satisfait